welcome back to the unica's Radio Hour
I'm your Jedi host Robert Stanley
broadcasting live from Palm Springs
California on the greatest alternative
talk radio station on the planet kg RA
and you already knew that in case you
just happen to be tuning in thank you so
much this is the second hour and you
know what that means the lines are open
the lines are open if you have any
questions or comments mm or if you could
help me with my voice I'd appreciate it
the number here's 85kg RA live there's
no way you can forget that right 85kg RA
live and if you don't want to do that
actually comes out in just numerically
it's eight five five four seven two five
four eight three please write that down
if you don't already have it eight five
five four seven two five four eight
producer bill skywatcher will answer
your call put you on hold and I'll bring
you into the show any questions or
comments are welcome you can also if
you're the chat @kg RA you can
definitely put something up there we'll
see it in the chat or you can email me
at editor at unica's magazine.com
although I don't always check my email
during the show so it's probably best if
you call we will definitely look forward
to hearing from you
855 7 - 54 83 correct Thank You Allen
so how much longer are what is the
ultimate goal of the project you're
working on simulation well one of the
awesome things about it is that now that
we don't have to go through the the
gatekeepers these like mainstream media
and gatekeepers and now we can
disseminate ideas as long as you
formulate them really well cuz there's
so much noise so at least formulate the
ideas really well and then you can
disseminate some people from around the
world right now from all different
countries around the world are pinging
us and they're like they're commenting
and they're saying oh my gosh this
changed my life or I started building a
community around this subject in my area
and so I'm like damn that's what's up so
if we can inspire people from around the
world to think more critically about the
ultimate nature of reality and what
their North Star is and all this type of
stuff through these interviews that's a
big one and then also
another one is that you know it's kind
of its kind of ridiculous that like
isn't one of the most interesting things
about life when we're born is that
there's no like there's no Canon there's
no operating system there's no manual
and so that whole notion that we were
talking about where the child is born
into the world they have to remember
that they come from source that they
have to ever find out what their North
Star is right and go and pursue it and
surround themselves with good mentors
and people to help them get there and
stuff like that you know that why is
there so so I'm working on a big
synthesis that I think can be really
relatable as like a Canon for people so
have a really good compression algorithm
for the most profound knowledge on the
planet so I'm working on that and then
oh and then also like it's kind of
ridiculous that you know why is it that
fifty thousand people can fill sports
stadiums but fifty thousand people can't
fill a stadium to talk about the
direction of civilization it's read it's
kind of its kind it's funny cuz we're
it's we're exactly in the game which is
to be and where the sports teams are
empty ninety percent of the time there
is 22 players and like football pads
that are you know crashing into each
other
you know what I mean and and stuff like
that and fifty thousand people are you
know tribally roaring at them but if you
make a panel with different leaders in a
specific field about the trajectory of
our planet you'll get you know a
thousand people or like sometimes you
get crickets and so it's and so we're
we're trying to fill sports stadiums
with curious intellectuals curious
spirits for full-day multidisciplinary
events everything from meditations to
comedy skits to you know those game
shows we were talking about all the way
to fireside chats all these types of
things oh yeah so that's another part of
the vision creative warehouses there's
so many interesting aspects of it we'll
see where it ends up going
Wow I hadn't thought of that but it
sounds good that sounds actually like a
really great activity that we could
engage in as far as you're helping to
unite people yeah okay so anyway um do
we have a quarter of the signals Connor
if we don't have I have one more story
to share if we if we don't have a
question okay
sure um go ahead Robert you'll I think
you'll enjoy the story but you know one
of my friends Tom Osborne grew up in a
village in Kenya and when he's growing
up there it's you know imagine a village
in Kenya is not no running water and the
electricity these types of things and he
in eighth grade realized that this was a
bifurcating moment of his life when he
was taking a test because if he took the
did the test really well he got into the
boarding school in Nairobi in Kenya and
so he ended up taking the test while
taking his county seat in the boarding
school in Nairobi and he got electricity
running water computers alumni network
of leaders of the country in Kenya right
next thing he knows after he graduates
in school he's going to Harvard in
Cambridge and so and soon Wow his life
trajectory went from a village in Kenya
to Harvard from just these bifurcating
moments of life and so now he goes back
to the village and it's so hard to
relate you know you know spiritually at
that point
oh yeah also that another aspect of it
is like with that like being in the
village like you're totally cool just
being like I'll just sit in a lawn chair
in the village or on a rock and just be
for hours just be here in the Western
world if you're not [ __ ] productive
with your time oh my god you're falling
behind in the hierarchy you can't just
be and so weird you also transform
people's consciousness with holding
space with one of my friends Ori Shapira
and things like that so just holding
space for just be and transforming
consciousness is also very California
thing trying to get that back
[Laughter]
I know I know
yeah it's weird it's weird being back
here um since you brought that up about
Canyon I did meet somebody exactly like
that some years ago
my son had to have surgery the I was I
was very concerned about making sure he
got the best care naturally because
surgery is there's no such thing as
minor surgery in my opinion and this
wasn't minor surgery anyway so I was
really panicky about getting a
specialist that was a proven
track-record okay and I was referred to
a guy named dr. oka rocky and his whole
family was from Kenya I'm not sure if he
was born there but he he had all the
benefits of all the medical schooling
here in the u.s. he was that he he ran
teams of people to run these to operate
these da Vinci machines you know the the
robotic arms that do stuff and you know
invasive but it's but it's really
precision but you have to be a good
operator because you screw up and the
Machine will screw you up so right this
guy and the other thing about with him
was I don't know what it was probably a
skin condition but even though he was
used African there was large parts of
his skin that were white you know so
just just the visual like III did had no
idea who he was I was talking on the
phone but he was so so calm and and very
precise you know like he gave me
everything in context of like you know
all the information I needed he was
giving it to me very calmly and just
saying you know he's gonna be fine and
here's what we can do for him just bring
him in transfer him to the hospital and
I'll run the team and all this stuff I'm
like okay cool then I meet the guy he
walks like visually I'm like whoa well
that's weird and then he said you know
hi I'm dr. Oh crickey people think I'm
Irish you know my name is I'm actually
from Kenya and yeah he's telling me all
this stuff and uh like I'm still kind of
in shock that oh wait a minute my son
you surgery and I you know I want the
best guy and you're the best guy and
like I'm what I'm thinking about it I'm
like flashing eyes because this is when
Obama was in office and I'm thinking
now here's a guy that loves loves this
country because it's given him all these
opportunities and he's actually using
that he's paying it forward by using his
skill the skills that he's developed to
help other people save other people's
lives instead of just telling people how
to live their lives he's giving them
opportunity to continue living their
lives in a healthy manner and I was just
like floored by this guy I didn't ask
him about his politics because that
meant nothing to me
but I was just looking at him thinking
well that's that's the American dream
his family came here from Kenya I'm sure
it wasn't like you know like you said
it's not terribly advanced not that
there's these kind of people these
potentialities are everywhere for
everybody
and that that's that's what I want to
see more of happening and it's not an
American thing per se migui had I feel I
know this upsets people but I really
think that the constitution of the Bill
of Rights was a gift that by benevolent
beings just it not and they didn't write
it just subtly suggested some things to
the key people like hey you know it'd be
a good idea you know and Java that would
be a good idea you know of course that
was it that those does does or I think
that came after the fashion first thing
you had to get the Constitution yeah
well that's what the guess that's that
Constitution because it had its negative
liberties for anybody who doesn't know
what that means if there's a list of
negative liberties there which protects
us from tyranny in the government
because the founder is Nijo that's human
nature power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely absolutely so the
the more these these people rise up in
society and have these roles where
they're basically you know is in charge
of everything they're going to a beat
somehow somewhere they're going to abuse
it and that's what the Constitution is
written is is to constrain the
government from basically you know so I
that's that of all the places I've been
to I've been to 59 countries so far all
the places I've been to
I mean I love other countries but
there's something something very unique
and special about the United States of
America and specifically the
Constitution yeah absolutely agreed and
there is also something very special
about the Magna Carta too and there's
also some oh yeah that started it and
and it's it's almost as though when
you're born with so many privileges that
you forget that people worked really
fricken hard to try and put these things
together and that it's really important
to remember them so to be of really
vigilant student of history and care
about that a lot and also to realize
that it's not over that there's still
new amendments that need to be made
there's still new ways for us to update
the code of our world to deploy an
update that maximizes more prosperity
and so those are both key there is to
realize how far a hundred billion humans
build civilization before us and also
that we have to make sure the seventh
generation principle moving forward of
the indigenous that please be very very
considerate about seven generations
forward about every action that we take
yeah Annie yeah what emotions I don't
know if you're aware this play no
question no call no there I don't worry
about it
don't take it personal let's say this is
a thing this particular style if I don't
ask if we don't ask the right questions
people do not respond to that because
we're having a conversation it doesn't
feel like there's a lot of room if we
were just hey look if we wanted to do
something polarizing and throw out some
really you know leading questions I'm
sure people would respond just to just
to say yeah I don't like that or oh yeah
I'm on board it's like but we're having
this exchange here who wants its totally
genuine very good spontaneous it's not
like planned and yeah it's it doesn't
leave a lot of room for people to jump
in I mean I've even had people like
Richard Hoagland on here and he's a
fascinating guest and we but the thing
is because we're just because it is just
a conversation instead of like a topic
driven thing like what immigration or
something you know but but you okay
you're talking about the global economy
me the latest numbers are it's like over
240 trillion dollars worth of debt
worldwide so the system's broken okay
most people don't want to talk about it
but it's been in the news a few times
and I look at that number and I think
well actually I think this it was it's
more there's more debt than there is
equity well how did that happen and then
more importantly how the heck do we fix
that
Jubilee did we get a Jubilee can we
reset I mean come on what the heck it's
it's the Sun it can't we can't keep
going like this especially in the United
States the way they keep just voting in
deeper a date or they what do they call
that the debt ceiling they just keep
raising the debt ceiling which is not
raising anything it's digging a deeper
ditch for us financially and otherwise
and the only way we stay afloat is what
through our military can we also
acknowledge how and this is I think such
a key component for those that are
thinking about things and from that lens
is that when you go back to the origins
of these this of this type of thinking
even the origin the origin of this type
of thinking really came from the first
time that someone came up to someone
else
and said who owns this land no one owns
this land this is land that just we grow
food on or we and we enjoy we live under
etc and then yeah the idea is that oh
wow this cave has it's a bigger cave
this cave has more light in it or this
cave has more things for me to do in it
or food in it or whatever it is and
these these little incremental instances
in our evolution as best as we
hypothesize were the reasons that we
were just Bob beating each other over
the head with violence for each other's
land for each other's resources and the
in the the invention of an exchange like
a like a currency is a it's a it's in so
many ways useful in many ways
and at and now also like are we really
that we're just so in our own egos and
ruts about this one way of exchanging
value that we haven't realized other
ways of exchanging value beyond currency
because right now these markers for
well-being being something like GDP is
totally not but not not it we were just
giving an example of holding space or
just being right if I'm just being with
nature if I'm just being and enjoying my
my life I'm I'm I'm actually not valued
whatsoever Baha'i by but I'm but I'm
actually very calmly enjoying nature I
might have a deep open heart I might be
yeah more spiritually connecting so it's
like than if I was being stuck in the
economic machinery doing something I
don't love so yeah yeah well that's what
I actually when I was in Hong Kong I
picked up a job working in social
compliance which is when an auditor goes
to a factory they're looking for a lot
of different things but but something
has changed I don't know exactly when
this started but they look for any kind
of violations of the workers and the
environment that's what social cumquats
why cause social compliance it's not
just specific legal stuff it's you know
like permits and stuff it's it's about
protecting the planet and the people
that work in these factories which is
it's gotten better and but of course
there's there are violations and the
reason that the companies especially in
America the corporations when they hire
these they subcontract these factories
is they don't want the liability you
know so like Apple they had a problem
with their some of the Foxconn is one of
the biggest factories in China and there
was people jumping out the windows and
kill themselves because they were just
so distraught by the conditions there
because where people are not machines
you know right and it's those jobs
really should have been automated at a
long time ago because there's other
things we can do with our time and
actually in the US in the army book a
lot of people including myself we're
very concerned about you know how much
stuff
gonna be automated how many people are
going to be displaced from their jobs
but it's if they're if we move to a more
equitable Devine sort of Brotherhood or
fellowship based not even an economy
it's just like he said a way of life
then automation will take over a lot of
the just the drudgery the you know the
the repetitive work which kind of drives
humans crazy and so if you have advanced
machinery and you you program it so that
it is doing something that's beneficial
for everybody including the planet then
that's a good thing but if you program
it to be like you know a better soldier
or weapons system I mean that's that's
is that's you know everybody's gonna
suffer from something like that
unfortunately so anyway I do think that
and we're not talking about guaranteed
income that's the other thing is a
fallacy that's not that's not it it's a
it's about inclusive everybody sharing
everything inclusive stake hold the
forbid the food forbidden word here is
communist
or just or just it's never the inclusive
stake holding I know I should okay go
ahead go ahead and play on that but just
like just such a easy way of
understanding I know that's a dislike
you you already use the platform so much
and for and for like just using a
ride-sharing service like an uber or a
lyft
that you they why why is it just the
initial investors and employees and
founders are the ones and even the
employees that come in later are the
ones that get anything the shareholders
when really the drivers themselves plus
the passengers that take all the rides
are the ones that build off so much of
the value so to tokenize that and to
give people inclusive stake holding and
also the headquarters of these companies
is literally in the downtown San
Francisco area that they themselves can
become inclusive stakeholders in the
damn communities there as well and
supported that way so that that
mentality I think is and and yeah and go
go go go ahead and take it where or
well yeah I don't like that word either
because it's been people say that we've
already had communist countries but I
disagree it's never really been fully
implemented so to the full extent it in
the sense that there is everything is a
collective as you said then everything
is shared because everybody would know
and act as though we're all family you
know when you're in a family you share
stuff and you don't say hey you need to
pay me or whatever like that is just
like there's in other words the level of
competition has to decrease gradually
until the because the level of
cooperation and/or collaboration
increases and that's where we're really
all going to win everybody so that's
that's really the only reason I bring
that up because that's a very loaded
term and I know a lot of people say they
are communists socialists whatever which
but I'm not sure they even understand
what that is and ultimately the Soviet
Union was never really one hundred
million people have died trying to make
it happen yeah yeah yeah China yeah
another things like that that's not
that's not true come around the world
yes I'm communal it's not communal
living not at all so anyway I'm just I'm
just bringing it up because I know
that's all okay so here's a loaded
question everybody that you guys can
participate in to what I'd like to know
really seriously I'd like to know first
of all are you reading the ami books if
so what's your opinion of them more
importantly though what do you do to
increase the amount of love in your
heart that's a pretty simple question I
know you can answer it I know I'd like
to hear from you I think Alan would too
and I'm sure yeah it would be it would
be very helpful yeah if you if you can
answer that question I will send you a
gift how about that all right we'll get
your number or your address off the air
producer bill get that if you would be
so kind as to call in with answer that
question please what are you doing to
increase the love in your heart your
daily lives lost quotient on a date your
love potion we yeah yeah okay so
for number eight five five four seven
two fifty 483 one more time eight five
five four seven two five four eight
three yeah you know it was called so we
have in IQ the intelligent quotient then
there was they came up with the
counterpart to that was you and most
emotional intelligence is actually what
they called it but but I think they
missed the mark there the love quotient
is a lot more accurate because just it's
such a random thing oh he's so emotional
you know give him a higher score what
does that mean
you know what you need more empathy okay
that's I'm on board with empathy but
yeah anyway other aspects to that like
emotion regulation I can regulate your
emotions another aspect that is
perspective taking you can more easily
get behind the eyes of another person
there's a lot of aspects to EQ that are
really really strong but yeah lq the
love quotient how deeply can you tap
into all that is sometimes we say we
have one foot in the physical world and
we have one foot in the in the melting
into all that is into spirit or source
and that is beautiful to be able to
balance those two well yeah and that's
okay one of my grandfather's a very
spiritual guy he told me that balance is
always found between two extremes and
that stuck with me because I mean it's
first of all it's true it's a very edge
to a cure I should say it's an accurate
statement because it's observable to be
true and the hard part though is knowing
that as it's happening to you yeah so
you don't want to be I think Buddha said
something about not too tight not too
loose you know and and you know in order
to be in tune with creation because it's
it's an ebb and flow all the time mm-hmm
so I don't know I'm really excited I
know I'm an optimist but it's like I
hate a view that some days are more
different examples the too tight the too
tight are the ones that are in the
financial industry in the suits going
around and in exchanging all the
numbers and banking and self-dealing and
also to tighter the self-dealing
politicians and physicians and food
industries and all this type of stuff
media companies then the Toulouse as
well in many ways are the ones that are
on the they call them now cosmic voyages
it's like sometimes I'm gonna I'm like
going somewhere with people and I'm like
you know I got a show the next day like
I got to get back and they're just like
yeah render to wherever the wind takes
them next and I'm just like I'm just
like okay that's cool like you can do
that but like you can be a little tight
and a little loose - yeah that was a
creative footage yeah all right so we
have a caller
Alan hang on hey Ronald you're on the
air
thanks for calling it I'm doing good
yeah our guest tonight is Alan
[Laughter]
interesting you're talking about finding
your North North Star you mean the North
Star or do you mean like this is it
different yeah yeah the North Star for
every human if for every child is born
into the world there's their own
beautiful creative potential that they
can achieve in the world their own paint
stroke of genius that they can bring to
the bring to our world that's good yeah
and I think what the question you had is
what do I do
yes increase your love yeah in your
heart what I do is I'm sure my desk gift
which is hopefully a good vibrations to
people around me either on the internet
or in real life you know when I'm out
and about in town and I like you said
and you smile to somebody and sort of
good smile back you know in most case
we're gonna smile back you know and so I
think if you if you give out that
positive vibration you will get it back
leapin not right away maybe not first
time you try it but in turn it will come
back you know and but you have to give
it in order to get it so you have to get
the chair the good vibration in order to
receive give vibrations hi yeah
absolutely
yeah that's what I'm getting weird yeah
well thank you for sharing that
love it I love it thank you
alright take care we'll see talk to you
soon thank you fred in that case you
threaded that anyway the simulation
project or what is it's just the how
many people have you interviewed so far
over 500 people yeah [ __ ] god I saw that
on your page hundred people in a year
and a half two it's been crazy yeah yeah
I'm just uh there's so many smart people
in so many different fields and so I'm
trying to share what they're building
and how they got there and why it's
important with as many people as
possible as fast as possible and so
there's just so many smart people to
feature actually Robert you know what's
really cool is also going on the road to
different countries and so we have an
invitation right now from picking
University in Beijing to go and
interview their professors in leadership
and so we're gonna do that in September
and I'm just jacked because like that's
how we bring the [ __ ] world together
that's how we do yeah all of a sudden
simulation has a bunch of interviews
from Peking University or from Buenos
Aires or from wherever in the world and
you're seeing that that we are all loved
we are all want peace and dignity we all
have our yeah families and and our goals
in life and stuff so these are those
tiny little things that I think that we
can do to bridge the culture Kousaka I
for the longest time have been wanting
to bring the United States and China
closer together to ensure maximum
prosperity moving forward into the
future so I'm really looking forward to
that and another really important one is
Silicon Valley in Los Angeles to bring
them together on the media and Hollywood
also with the tech
and science is happening up here so
bringing those two together is really
important there's a lot of these
actually you gave the quote balance is
found between two extremes and so like
yeah yeah yeah yeah well ask us and
maybe you should one of your questions
is it you can add to your list of
amazing questions is you know so what
are you doing professor to increase the
love quotient I love all right I
highlighted and bolded and underscored
love quotient and I changed it to
different
I mean I'm gonna turn that into a
question I'm gonna right now I'm
actually gonna go make it size like 36
in my notes because I'm gonna remember
that you know that's I love that elk you
baby love quotient that's so good yeah
yeah the elk you I can't date you if
you've been alone with elk does lo elke
people I see you on television a lot is
you know if you imagine a hierarchy of
people or actually it's a belt it's a
bell curve of like IQ right in the
middle yes the tail ends of the
distribution I wonder where those two
bell curves with lq i wonder how they
overlap like maybe someone that has
really high IQ this actually may be more
in the middle and someone with really
high lq could be maybe you know in the
middle or lower end or whatever so that
they don't necessarily they're not
necessarily come together lq and IQ and
EQ but they likely do come together if
you find yourself further on the bell
curve you're probably also quite able to
abstractly reason to a ton of different
variables and compute them which is in
many ways IQ and same thing with EQ and
lq are similar in some ways too
yeah but I don't think he's been written
I know there's an emotional intelligence
question metric I don't I don't know I
guess that could be applied or tweaked a
bit so that you could get to this I
don't know any it's not really that's
it's not that it requires a science a
rocket scientist to figure that out
there but I did
probably needs to be some kind of scale
so if anybody out there is interested in
putting that together that little metric
of the love quotient because I think
it's pretty easy to test obviously
people could lie about I don't know why
they would but I you know we I don't
know I just remember taking the IQ test
when I was younger and thinking man this
is a waste of time I don't I don't know
why this is something let me play on two
things there first thing is on the IQ
side there is something really
interesting about being able to
basically you're able to abstractly hold
a bunch of different variables in your
working memory and run a computation in
your head and so that's a big aspect of
IQ and then on an L Q measurement I
think what you mentioned earlier about
consonants is a big one you can
literally do fMRI or EEG and you can map
someone's level of consonants and what
is that it's doing things like seeing
the symmetry in there in the state of
what's going on and with the brain
activity or similarly with their heart
there's all this enough with like heart
math that's happening oh yeah right
right right there yeah hard math
Institute yes
and they write the energy field around
your heart okay okay well that's because
it was mentioned in the books the ami
books they had actually had a device
that could measure the level of your yes
your love quotient yeah they didn't say
quote quotient but I'm just using I
don't know I'm I like playing with words
so I thought that was actually a good
sort of branding you know something that
people can digest that the concept
alright and actually in our world I know
people are going to start using it and
probably like competing competing but if
you're competing on something that's
that's beautiful like that in a very
peaceful loving way you know it's like
hey yeah I really increase it look at
lookit I got look how high I got my love
quotient yeah Wow how'd you do that bro
yeah yes and you can joke around and be
like yo bro I'm so much more non-dual
than you are right
you know whatever you know oh we had
that joke on this show so good shout out
Samantha Stein I think said that one but
here's another here's another one is um
you can do a you can do a like a kind of
like a friendly way of just kind of like
you're basically poking at someone and
you're just saying like if they look
maybe like a little stressed and stuff
you can say hey how is your love
quotient right now and then they may
like kind of snap a little out of their
stress state and they're like thank you
for helping me with that moment you know
sometimes just asking a person yeah
sometimes just asking them how I I can
see you're struggling I see is there
anything I can do to help yeah you know
or like I said or just how are you
feeling right now it's like showing some
empathy yeah yeah yeah yeah it
definitely it kind of snaps people out
of that dissonant patterning genuine in
a very loving way he was interested yes
until I contact this huge really staying
present with the eyes and and also after
you asked the question how you feeling
this is it hey let me tell you something
when I was younger and I was working on
a lot of he called spiritual
metaphysical stuff I did I was doing
these thought experiments and one of
them was about telepathy just to see how
people would react it or if they could
even because I already knew telepathy
was real some of the extraterrestrials
were showing me that they actually not
only could send stuff but they were
receiving for sure they were like
reading my thoughts and they were
demonstrating the fact that they were
doing that okay which at first was
shocking but ultimately I got over it
and just realized okay well maybe that's
a good thing or at least I got a I got a
figure a way to make a positive
something positive out of it but anyway
I saw him like I'm walking around in the
city and I look at a person and like
mentally smile at them and say hiya how
you doing you know and it didn't happen
all the time but it was weird because
this person be walking down the street
you know kind of robotic and then they
suddenly look over at me you
no I mean for no frickin reason of the
fact that I was broadcasting to them
this thing you know and and I liked it
it really freaked me out it sounds like
oh oh well I don't want to abuse that
you know and I don't want to invade
people's minds obviously you know that's
not it but it but it was it see the
thing was I was just kind of testing the
waters I was putting my toe in the water
just to see if it support is this real
and if so what now what you know I mean
I look I think you're right
we have vocal cords for a reason but
there's something much deeper so there's
a much a greater level of clarity when
you we communicate through telepathy
it's not just words it's it's visuals
there's an emotion that comes with it
and sometimes it's extremely visceral
and so and the other thing is very
personal because the thing is even
though we're using ours and like well
okay or just right and but you're in
right now you're like conjuring you're
like your mind's going I know what an
apple looks like and I know what an
orange like and they're different so but
but the words I don't enough if suddenly
I'm not saying anything and I'm just
broadcasting in my mind I'm broadcasting
that I'm peeling an orange you know and
the smell of the oil wafting through the
air you know you're starting to kind of
like salivate a little bit like as man
that's a juicy really good orange so in
that regard I smell it a little bare I
did I smelled it a little bit I'm
serious I believe you but it's it's what
saying is that's part of our potential
or potentiality of in the future is
using these technologies okay but
there's techniques there's processes
there skills that we used to have you
have to learn that is gonna eclipse all
of this so-called digital skiff someone
is doing some a task and then they're
wearing an EEG and people are reading
their brain activity and then
they're basically doing it and then they
stop physically doing it and they go and
they just mentally think that they're
doing it and they just have it happening
within them that they're doing it yeah
same brain activity it's crazy
oh so that's also another interesting
when I wonder how much further we can go
into that field and proof stuff like
that also all the stuff about
manifesting people do this all the time
they go and they go in they they they
prepare for their own performances or
whatever it may be by mentally
visualizing themselves crush it and then
they yeah so then they that helps them
rock it there's also examples of like if
all these possibility space exists of
like you know Robert Stanley's future
trajectory or this child that's born
into the world their future trajectory
all the possibility space exists then
the iDEN idea is how do I collapse the
future in the direction that optimizes
my trajectory towards my Northstar and
that is that requires you in the morning
and in the night to not be a dopamine
monkey and be grabbing this device but
it requires you to just chill be and
literally meditate on the beautiful
future that you're building and envision
yourself achieving those goals in the
North Star yeah the longer and stronger
an individual visualizes whatever it is
that they want or need for themselves
and others the greater the likelihood
that it will manifest in this reality
and the reason is because as you said it
kind of collapses we know that the
observer through the slit experiment we
know that the observer effects the
outcome well if if you don't observe it
it'll still have an outcome but it
probably won't be the one you want or
need and so this goes back to what I
saying before about always expecting
someone or something else to do this for
you well yeah they probably will but
you're not gonna like it as much as the
thing as you because we have this thing
and unfortunately we've been one of the
big lies here on this planet is that our
imagination is just an illusion
it's basically relegated to a
non-essential function when in fact it's
it's the opposite it's one of the
greatest abilities or gifts that we were
given as divine beings is this so-called
imagination ability to imagine or
visualize something in a non-physical so
that it can then become part of the
physical realm so that you know it's I
know it sounds overly simplistic but
this it's a very you know well-known
psyching I can go a little deeper into
this - go ahead
there's even and I still have yet to to
get a better understanding of this but
the general one of the schools of
thought for the way that things like
creativity emerged in us now is that we
can basically take in our environment
and we can we can abstractly reason all
of those different future possibilities
that exist and then the better that
someone is at that the more they are of
like a creative genius but if you go too
far in the direction of always
creatively abstractly reasoning all
different futures and having difficulty
with you all that type of stuff then
there's some some people think that that
is what can cause people to go off on
too much of a deep end on that on that
as well and they I want to say that it's
Robert Sapolsky has some work in this
field and that it's a it's a genetic
evolution I'm not sure if it's one gene
to gene if those were the numbers
associated with what I was just
mentioning but that didn't know that
that amount of genes was associated with
it but that essence of it is such a
critical part because in order for you
to envision a North Star you you have to
be able to abstractly reason at least
these different trajectories for example
Robert I would have been a completely
different human being if I would have
stayed in Sioux Falls South Dakota
completely different and so on by my
making the move to Silicon Valley
fornia by making them yeah I changed I
bifurcated in my life trajectory and
some people argue that this Alan that
still in Sioux Falls is living in some
parallel universe right now yeah yeah
and that one can even potentially in
their dream state or even right now just
kind of go between the different
parallel universes and go and live in
those realms for better they can come
through it's complicated it's
interesting it's hypothetical but so can
you abstractly reason what your North
Star is can you see the different paths
to get there and what is most optimal
for you because it does require that
kind of like that that creativity that
is also at times can drive people crazy
Roberts some people even feel like
including me feel like we're swimming in
a sea of ideas all the time and that
yeah we have to like as quickly as we
can just try and grab grab the ideas and
and and write them down and try and send
them to people to execute because we
can't execute all of them but these are
the people that are so [ __ ] obsessed
with looking at civilization and being
like that's not the [ __ ] best way to
do that we can design it and engineer it
better and here's how to do that and if
you run that process more often in your
head as an adult and a child you will
become a better designer and engineer of
our future Wow
okay so you you meet a lot of you know a
lot of people in Silicon Valley is that
what they're working on or is it just
the next gadget Silicon Valley is
[ __ ] insane this place is so insane
yeah like to find that I mean I mean
like well I guess first of all um the
fact that literally Google is here
Facebook is there Apple is here LinkedIn
is here Twitter is here uber is like all
of these like venture capital firms are
here you know there's a place called
Sand Hill Road they here that just has
literally a one after the other all
these different venture capital firms
and you know only and you know just that
amount of power
of all those companies that we were just
talking about plus all of the funding
for them it's like it's just a massive
Network effect that's happened in this
area and you know that's a that's see
here's one of the things we were just
talking about today actually we had okay
I was I was interviewing one of the guys
here on-site at a ranch X and his name's
Newton and he's got he's a very
interesting guy working on doing things
like curing Parkinson's and the way he's
doing that is by inserting a very tiny
little grain of rice that it's like it's
the size of grain of rice but what it is
is it smells in there it's a neural
prosthetic and what it does is it goes
into the exact targeted area where you
have Parkinson's and it goes and it adds
a virus that that that goes away after
you're done but it adds a virus that
makes the neurons in the area that is
targeted it makes them able to be
adjusted and impacted by light it's
called up whoa it's called optogenetics
it's a new field where you can literally
modulate neuro neuronal activity in the
brain through light and so he's at he's
shown 900 people they've helped with
Parkinson's through this process and so
we know there's a big variety of
different things that's happening in the
space right and all those fields that I
listed at the beginning and they're all
kind of smashing together merging but
that's one of the best ways to become a
polymath is to go and explore all those
different fields and gain at least some
foundational knowledge because then what
you get is you get the novel connections
between disciplines that so many people
lack so how could you mesh together
something like neuroscience and like the
decentralization technologies or how
could you
mesh something like the the ways that
we're processing all of the the data
that's coming in from autonomous
vehicles with their cameras and how
could you - how could you mess that with
the with the biometrics that are within
our bodies maybe there's a way to like
people are doing already which is
putting a
[ __ ] camera in our mirrors in our in
our in our bed in our bedrooms and
bathrooms and stuff which literally will
scan my my biometric state in the
morning and see Oh like you must have
you know your your your where your hips
are is a little bit wider or less and so
it's constant you know readout of even
pupils is another big one these these
these front-facing cameras on these
devices have gone have are getting
they're already doing the facial scans
to unlock the phone right well you can
do use his crazy Robert you can
literally see the you can see pulsations
you can see people's heart rate by the
front facing camera on phones because
you can see you can see the little tiny
micro micro vasculature the little oh
okay the little pulse a yes yes yeah
with that type of all the sensors in
these devices to be able to read out all
these things so this is what all these
people here or but a lot of people here
some this was sorry just quick just
quickly finishing that that this that
this you know the guy that we were
talking to Newton that the ideas before
him a person came on to talk about this
Global Fund for women and women's
equality around the planet and how there
are still so many countries around the
world where women are treated like
property where women are impregnated
against a will where women are on edge
that they're uneducated and because of
that they haven't they have a limited
degrees of freedom with where they want
to go in the world and so it's just
interesting dichotomizing those two
things where one of them is something
strategically around the world trying to
go and help people and increase their
degrees of freedom make women more
empowered around the world to pursuing
their North Stars and the other one is
like pretty much for you know curing
Parkinson's but also for you know people
that can really afford something that's
probably gonna cost half a million
dollars or more so yeah so here's this
dichotomy and I think people really do
feel like in Silicon Valley a lot of
people are are solving problems either
of the
hyper wealthy or that are so micro
fractionally irrelevant in like you
don't need a fifteenth a company that
does intercompany communication platform
you know what I mean you don't need that
go insolvent has redundant world problem
yeah and so that's one of the other
philosophies around here there's also a
lot of spirituality that's kicking in
from the counterculture days that was
still here and that that's yeah there's
an undercurrent of that I remember Jobs
had his thing about well he did have
some of that going on but he's not the
only thing I just figured there's a lot
of different people there that are
working on different projects and some
of it though that is kind of freaky with
the singularity and the transhumanist
movement um those those folks I that
kind of seems like a dead end to me or
at least not a place that I would want
to go and be part of at some point I
just and I like the the natural systems
much better connected reconnect with the
cosmos as opposed to this construct you
know the digital realm it's it's
virtually real sure-enough but I don't
know it's good this just strange times
that we're in here I've kind of feel
like this is a repeat of Atlantis in a
lot of ways and and want to talk about
that so much we started our you do know
we started our show we did a we did a
show on identifying and correcting
perverse incentives and we started that
panel we did an event around that topic
we talked a lot about self dealing and
embedded growth obligations and all
these other types of things but we I
started the show by giving a quick bit
on there have been so many previously
collapsed civilizations there's no
guarantee that us kindergarteners third
graders playing with these godlike
technologies is going to end up in the
singularity you know so yeah it's I know
it sounds good
it's a great sales job for some people
are founders great so it is it is like
don't you want to be part of that just
just jam this and get a lot of good yeah
or download your consciousness yeah into
a device nah they
some people will go for it though
because again I think that a lot of this
is based on fear or at least a lack of
love that's again this is the thing
about the ami books it's all about you
know balancing out your love quotient
with the science and if the science gets
too much then the whole thing just Falls
it's like an avalanche it's just gonna
it's it can't sustain itself it's just a
little unbalanced and I'm just gonna
come down so I don't know take away from
our conversation Robert I'm so happy
that you brought me into the
nomenclature love quotient constantly
tap into our own love quotient as well
as the love quotient of people around us
by just checking in yeah by tapping in
the meetings and evenings with their
families all this type of stuff I love
that it's great yeah yeah and in person
is better unfortunately that's making
it's it's a lot more difficult these
days because everybody's so connected to
their devices Robert can I make a quick
I want to make a go ahead yeah yeah
we're wrapping up in two minutes so
we're like what's your final word final
thoughts are everyone I'm extremely
grateful for Robert for hosting us on
his show thank you very much for tuning
in I also would love to um thank you all
for that watch also on on video across
our platforms as well huge thank you for
those that are interested in watching
some of these thought-provoking
interviews we have with leaders you can
find it simulation series.com or across
YouTube and Facebook Twitter Instagram
etc you can find us a simulation series
and also just everyone have more
conversations to your friends your
families co-workers people online on
social media about these pressing topics
that we talked about going to share more
about this idea of the love quotient
around the world and embody it more
ourselves talk about the ultimate nature
of reality more we need to do that more
often as a planet and just the
importance of supporting people like
Robert if you like his programs support
Robert help him continue building this
program help bill as well continue doing
his radio program help simulation do our
programs support these artists these
entrepreneurs these leaders in your
communities and
let's build the future together that's
that's a wrap from me thank you very
much
yeah excellent Thank You Alan for being
a guest and for you and all the great
work that you and your colleagues are
doing over there all right ladies and
gentlemen that concludes another episode
of the unica's radio hour as always I do
appreciate your listenership it's always
a privilege and a pleasure please be
good to yourselves and others and until
next time may the force be with you
Allen the you you do not have a go what
do you were call it a screen over your
microphone so when you get close and you
pop your peas it's very it's it's I can
hear we can hear you the point yeah I
can put a claw of any sort
you got suck put a sock on it
sock who works yet really have you done
that bill it has to be not a regular
wool sock but like um like a black like
a oh that's a wool sock or a nylon you
know like those you have a dress - yeah
exactly
Alan what funniest [ __ ] ever it's like a
[ __ ] got that on video man oh my god
that's gonna go pyro